빌사남의 간다는 세계적인 도시 그리고
제가 좋아하는 마천루들이 모여 있는
뉴욕 맨하튼에 왔습니다
[음악]
네 제가 지금 나와 있는 부분이 여기
타임스퀘어 인근인 가기 전에 이렇게
연기가 나는 곳 앞에 좀서 있습니다
그래서 많은 분들이 좀 되게 많이
궁금해 하실 것 같은데 뉴욕에 오면
이렇게 연기나는 맨홀이 되게 많아요
여기 이제 대부분의 건물들이 난방을
그 증기 시스템을 좀 사용을 합니다
근데 그게 이제 파이프가 워낙
오래되다 보니까 거기 좀 틈이 많이
생기거든요 틈이 생기면서 이런
연기들이 좀 많이 나오고 있습니다
그리고 특히 겨울철 같은 경우에는이
연기가 더 많은 거 같아요네 그래서
좀 약간 아날로그적이고 하지만 뭔가
뉴욕의 감성을 느낄 수 있는 어 그런
장면이지 않을까네 그렇게 생각을
[음악]
합니다 그래서 저희가 지금
타임스퀘어에 가고 있는데 어
타임스퀘어 역사에 대해서 좀 설명을
드리자면 원래는 타임스퀘어가
아니었어요 그래서 그 전에는 아예
명칭이 달랐습니다 1904년에 어
뉴욕 타임스 가 이쪽으로 좀 이전을
하면서 이제 타임 스퀘어라는 명칭이
좀 생겼고 그리 많은 분들이 또
아시는게 연날 그니까 12월 31일
날 여기 또 행사를 또 많이 하잖아요
그래서 그 행사가 1907년부터
했다라고 합니다 그래서 굉장히 좀
역사가 깊은 그런 행사라고 좀 보시면
될 거
같은데네 그래서 좀이 타임스퀘어 같은
경우에는 매년 약 5천만 명의
관광객이 온다라고 합니다 그리고 여기
타임스퀘어는 그 브로드웨이에 워낙
이제 극장이나 극하는 데가 되게
많은데 저도 예전에 거기서 그
라이언킹을 좀 봤었는데 어 되게
유명한 어 그런 뭔가 연극이나 이런
극장가가 많이 밀집되어 있어 가지고
많은 분들이 좀 찾는 곳이라고 보면
될 거 같고 되게 화려한 광고판이
되게 많잖아요 그래서 광고판이
1920년도에 이제 처음 시작해
가지고 원래는 이렇게 좀 디지털화 되
있지 않았겠죠 어 그런 연극 같은 거
홍보하기 위해서 간판 형식으로 됐다가
어 최근에 이렇게 좀 이렇게 디지털로
좀 바뀌면서 많은 기업들이 이쪽에 좀
홍보를 하려고 많이 하는 거 같아요
그래서 어 뭐 우리 기업 같은
경우에는 뭐 삼성이나 LG 우리나라
기업들도 이쪽에 좀 많이 광고를
하려고 하는 거 같습니다 삼성역을 뭐
이렇게 타임스퀘어 럼 만들겠다라는
광고판 허가를 좀 많이 내주고 있는데
어 저는 개인적으로 그 삼성역에 있는
그 광고판의 화질이 정말 너무 좋아요
그래서 제가 봤을 때
타임스퀘어에 뭐 꿀리지 않습니다 저는
삼성역에 좀 이런 되게 화려한
전광판들이 좀 많이 들어와서 많은
관광객들 아니면 이제 그 국내에 계신
분들이 이쪽 삼성동 쪽도 삼성역 쪽도
많이 좀 찾아줬으면
[음악]
좋겠습니다 최근에 타임스퀘어에 반도
건설이 건물을 매입했습니다 그래서
여기 지하 1층부터 지상 2층까지
매입을 했는데 그 매입을 한 이유가
한국의 fmb 알리겠다라고 해가지고이
건물에 저희 한국 fmb 음식점들이
좀 많이 들어올 것 같아요네 그래서
최근에 지금 한류가 되게 열풍인데
한국 음식에 대한 관심이 되게
높아졌습니다 그 아마 제가 봤을 때
한국 fnb 기업이 들어왔을 때 많은
분들이 되게 찾아올 것 같아요 그래서
타임스퀘어 오시는 분들은이 건물을
방문하셔도 좋을 것 같습니다 저는 그
반도 건설의 행보가 되게 좀 놀랍다고
생각을 하는데 미국 진출할 때 그
LA 있는 아파트 건물을 좀 지었어요
보라라 아파트를 지었는데 그게 이제
완판이 되고 어 지금이 타임스퀘어
건물도 매입하고 최근에 또 주상복합
건물도 매입을 했습니다 오피스 건물을
주거용으로 좀 바꿀 예정이라고 하는데
정말 좀 미국 시장의 진심인 거
같아요 그래서 앞으로 반도 건설이
어떻게 하는지도 지켜보시면 좋을 것
[음악]
같습니다 매각된 사례 하나 좀
설명드릴 건데 지금이 뒤에 보이는
건물입니다 그래서 타임스스퀘어
타워라는 건물인데
2021년도에 약 20억 달러의
매각이 됐습니다 그 하나로 보자면 약
2조 6천억 정도 됩니다 그래서
어마어마한 금액이 좀 매각이 됐는데이
건물 위치가 좀 굉장히 좋은 거
같아요 광고판도 되게 좀 화려하게 돼
있습니다 그래서이 건물은 타임스퀘어서
그렇게 멀지가 않기 때문에 여러분들
한번 뭐 지나다니다가 보시면 좋을 것
같고요 뉴욕이 다 좋은데 어 대마초
냄새가 너무 많이나요 진짜 코가 찌
정도로 냄새가 되게
심한데 지금 저는 어 센트럴 파크에
매각된 사례라 오번 에비뉴에 매각된
사례를 가려고 하는데 지금 여기
비계가 설치되어 있는 곳에 와
있어요이 비계가 설치된 이유가 뭐냐면
뉴욕시에서 일정 기간이 지나면은
반드시 보수를 하게끔 이렇게 규정이
돼 있어요 그래서 예를 들면 자동차
검사와 같은 겁니다 그래서 일정 기간
이 지나면 무조건 검사를 받아야 되는
무조건 유지 보수를 해야 되는
뉴욕시의 규정이 있어요 그래서
뉴욕시는 워낙 그 오래된 건물들이
많기 때문에 이런 타일이 떨어지거나
이런 석재가 떨어지는 경우가 굉장히
많거든요 그래서 그거를 좀 방지하기
위해서 이렇게 비계를 설치한 다음에
일정 기간이 지나면 반드시 공사를 할
수 있게 이렇게 돼 있습니다 그래서
우리나라 같은 경우에는 따로 이런
규정이 없어요 대부분 다 이제 62어
전쟁 이후에 지어진 건물들이 진짜
엄청 오래된 건물이라는 진짜 100년
이상 된 건물들이 많이 없잖아요
앞으로 좀 더 기간이 지나면 이런
규정이 좀 생겨야 되지 않을까네
그렇게 생각을 합니다 그래서 생각보다
어 우리나라 건물들도 그렇게 오래되지
않았는데 이렇게 타일이 떨어지는
경우를 저는 많이 봤어요네 그렇다
보니까 좀 우리나라도 좀 뉴욕 시처럼
어 이렇게 좀 정기적으로 보수공사를
할 수 있게 이런 규정들이 좀
생겨야지 이런 보행자의 안전을 좀
지킬 수 있다라고 생각을 합니다
네 센트럴 파크로
[음악]
가시죠네 그래서 저희가 센트럴 파크
가다가 지금 억만장자의 길 57번
가에 좀 나와 있는데 지금 뒤에
보이는이 건물이 되게 대표적인 그런
초고층 빌딩이라고 좀 보시면 될 거
같습니다 지금 명칭은 이제 센트럴
파크
타워고수 3억에 판다라고 해가지고 어
영상 좀 나왔었는데 그만큼 되게 좀
최고가의 어 좀 이런 주거 시설들이
있는 건물이라고 좀 보시면 될 거
같습니다 이쪽에 이제 초고층 빌딩들이
좀 많이 몰려 있게 된게 여기 위치
자체가 그 미드타운이 이제 센트럴
파크 남단 쪽에 위치하고 있습니다
그래서 여기 상층에는 센트럴 파크
뷰가 매우 잘 보여요네 매우 잘
보이는 위치에 있어 가지고 지금 이쪽
57번가 길을 억만장자의 길이라고 좀
불립니다 어 여기 있는 초고층
빌딩들은 대부분 다 2000년
중반부터 2010년도에 좀 많이
지어진 그런 건물이라고 좀 보시면 될
거 같아요 그 지금 진짜
높이가 지금 고개를 거의 고개가 아플
정도로 어 굉장히 높은데 대부분 다
이제 400m 좀 넘어요 예 400m
아마 감이 안 오실 것 같은데
우리나라로 치자면 그 LCT 정도의
높이라고 보시면 될 거 같습니다
LCT 한 400m 좀 넘으니까 그
정도 높이라고 좀보 될 같고 그래서
되게 얇지만 되게 높게 올라와
있습니다 그래서이 건물을 처음 지을
때 그 공권을 많이 매입을 했어요
그래서 인근에 있는 건물의 공권을 좀
같이 매입을 해 가지고 되게 오랫동안
어 지은 건물이라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다 타이웨이 빌딩 같은 경우에는
이런 넓이가 되게 좁아요 그래서 한
18m 정도 되는데 이렇게 18m
이렇게 400 까지 어 올라가 있는
건물이라고 보시면 될 것 같습니다
그래서 진짜 너비가 18m men
가로길 넓이보다 조금 더 넓은
가로수길이 한 15m 정도 되니까
그래서 그만큼 되게 좁지만 이렇게
올라가 있는 어 그런 건물이라고
보시면 될 거
[음악]
같습니다 어 저는 센트럴 파크에 와서
지금 커피 한 잔 마시고 있는데 어
센트럴 파크온 진짜 올 때마다 너무
좋은 거 같아요 그래서 처음 개장한게
1858년에 개장을 했는데 그때
당시에 좀 도시아 되게 빠르게
됐었거든요 근데 이런 거를 좀 막고
좀 공원을 만들면 좋겠다라고 해서
1858년에 이제 센트럴 파크를
만들었는데 진짜 몇백년이 넘게 그
명성도 유지하고 좀 대표적인 매네
7의 공원이고 정말 세계적인 공원이
되지 않았나 이렇게 생각을 합니다
어이 공원이
생기면서 여기 인근에 있는 부동산
가격들이 굉장히 좀 많이 올랐어요
그래서 대표적으로 좀 아까 그
57번가 억만장자의 거리에 있는 그런
부동산처럼 여기는 진짜 센트럴 파크
뷰가 어떤지에 따라서 부동산 가격이
진짜 천차 만별입니다 그래서 좀이
공원 인근으로 좀 부동산 가격도 좀
많이 다르다 뭐이 부분을 좀
기억하시면 될 거 같고 한국도 좀
비슷한 거 같아요 그래서 한국도 뭐
예를 들어서 구정 로데오 같은
경우에도 도산공원 인근 붙어 있는
데가 제일 비싸
어 그리고 도산공원 뷰가 어떻게
보이느냐에 따라서 부동산 가치가 또
달라지기도 하고 그 성수동 같은
경우에는 서울숲 그니까 뭐 갤러리아
레라지에이 서울숲 뷰가 어떤지에
따라서 부동산 가치가 또 달라지고
그리고 지금 연남동 같은 경우에는 뭐
연트럴 파크도 있고 그리고 앞으로 그
용산 공원도 이제 개발될 예정이지요
그래서 거기 인근에 있는 부동산
가격도 용산 공원이 어떻게 보냐에
따라서 가치가 좀 많이 달라질 것
같습니다 우리나라는 사실이 한강 뷰
되게 중요하게 생각하잖아요 뷰가
어떤지에 따라서 부동산 가치가 좀
많이 달라지는데 여기 뉴욕 같은
경우에는 물론 이제 허드 승강이 뭐
잘 보이느냐에 따라서 또 가치가
달라지기도 하지만 그거보다는 센트럴
파크 뷰가 굉장히 좀 중요하다 어
이렇게 보시면 될 거 같습니다 그래서
저기 뒤에 보이는 저 건물들도 어
정말 저기 꼭대기 올라가면이 센트럴
파크가 한 눈에 다 보이거든요 그리고
여러분들이 좀 감이 안 오실 수도
있는데 센트럴 파크가 굉장히 커요
그래서 우리나라로 비교하자면 그
올림픽 공원에 한 두 배 정도
면적이라는 될 거 같습니다 그리고 어
한 여의도 면적에 한 1분의 정도
면적이라는 아마 대략 체감하실 수
있지 않을까네 그렇게 생각을 하고
그리고 저는 여기 공원도 너무 좋지만
저기에 그 약간 그 호수 같은게
있거든요네 호수에서 여기 초고층
빌딩을 바라보는 뷰가 정말 멋져요
그래서 저가 여기 올 때마다
조깅하면서 저기 그 호수에 있는
쪽에서 여기를 항상 바라보는데 정말
장관입니다 그리고 저는 여기 있다가
저기 그 5번 애비뉴를 갈 예정이에요
거기 매각된 사례도 좀 설명드리고
그리고 거기에 이제 트럼프 타워도
있거든요 그래서 트럼프 타워도 좀
간략하게 설명을 드리도록
하겠습니다 오늘 날씨가 너무 좋네요
[음악]
센트럴 파크 지나가다가 어 플라자
호텔 앞에 와 있습니다 플라자 호텔은
아마 다들 아실 것 같은데 어 나홀로
지배에서 캐빈이 묵었던 어 숙소인데
뉴욕을 처음 알게 된게 어떻게 보면
나홀로
지인데코 보시면 될 거 같아요
여러분들 잘 아시겠지만 플라자
합의도이 플라자 호텔에서
[음악]
했었거든요 5번가를 걷다가 트럼프
타워 앞에 나와 있습니다 어 트럼프
타워는 원래는 처음에 지어질 당시에
굉장히 좀 비싸게 이제 판매를 하면서
원래는 미분양이 근데 트럼프가 전략을
되게 잘 세운게 뭐냐면 일부러
사람들을 줄을
세웠어요네이 분양을 받은 사람이
없지만 일부러 사람들을 줄을 세우면서
이제 소문이 나기 시작합니다 어
여기에 되게 유명한 사람들이
들어올거다 들어왔다 분양을 받았다
이런 소문들이 좀
나면서 굉장히 좀 유명해지기
시작했습니다 그래서 막 진짜 뉴욕
타임즈 기사에도 좀 실리고 그러면서
좀 유명인들을 많이 앞세우는 전략을
또 세웠어요 그래서 여기 지금
분양받았던 되게 유명인이 어 스티븐
스필버그 그다음에 마이클 잭슨 등과
같이 되게 유명한 스타들을 많이
분양을 시키고 마케팅을 엄청
잘했습니다네 그래서 되게 비싸게
판매했는데 불과하고 다 이제 분양이
된 것으로 좀 알려져 있는데 어 저는
보면서 느낀 점이 뭐냐면 아 뭔가 좀
고급화 전략으로 간다라고 하면은
일부러 이렇게 줄을 세우는 마케팅도
되게 중요하구나 뭐 이렇게 음식점들도
일부러 그런 거 같아 그니까 이제
진짜 일부러 줄을 세우면 사람들이
도대체 뭐가 있는 거지 도대체 무슨
맛이지 할 정도로 되게 궁금해
하잖아요네 그거와 같이이 트럼프
타워도 좀 이렇게 일부러 좀 줄을
세운 다음에 얼마나이 부동산이 좋길래
어 사람들이 관심을 받는 것까 뭐
이렇게 도 세웠고 그다음 이제
유명인들을 좀 내세워서 어 좀 이렇게
좀 마케팅을 잘한 어 그런 사례지
않을까네 그렇게 생각을 합니다
그래서이 트럼프 타워 안에 들어가면
되게 좀 금 색깔로 되게 화려하게 좀
돼 있는데 어 뉴욕에 오신다면
여러분들 트럼프 타워를 좀 한번
보시는 것도 괜찮을 것
같습니다 이번 애비뉴에 좀 매각된
사례를 좀 설명드리려고 하는데 어
트럼프 타워 바로 옆에 있는
건물입니다 그래서 저 건물
올해
2024년도 캐리에 매각이 됐어요 어
캐이 이제 매입을 했는데 캐링 회사는
9지 5 회사입니다 약 한 9억
7천만 달러 정도의 매각이 됐습니다
그래서 하나로 치자면 한 1조 3천억
정도 됩니다 대략네 그래서 그 정도의
매각된 그런 사례라고 보시면 될 거
같고 그래서 1층에는 그 알마니가
들어가 있어요 그리고 위에 층을 좀
보니까 저기 오피스가 있는 거 같은데
저기는 그래도 5번가 있데도 불구하고
공 상태인 거 같습니다 뉴욕뿐만
아니라 미국 전체적으로 좀 오피스
공실률이 되게 좀 심각합니다이 건물
같은 경우에도 5번가에 굉장히 좀
좋은 위치에 있긴 하지만 상부층의
오피스는 좀 공실이라 거 좀 알고
계시면 좋을 거
같아요 그리고요 5번 애비뉴를 좀
설명드리자면 여기에 이제 대표적인
그런 명품 거리라고 하죠 그러니까
이제 뭐 우리나라로 치면은 청담동
명품 거리처럼
이런 명품 업체들이 되게 즐비해 있는
거리라고 보시면 될 거 같습니다
그래서 이쪽으로 쭉 이어지는게 이제
5번 에비뉴들 이쪽으로 좀 더 가면은
저희가 잘 알고 있는 엠파이어
스테이트라인 뭐 록펠러 센터라는
이렇게 쭉 이어져 있어요 지금 이쪽
초입 부분 같은 경우에는 이런 명품
업체들이 좀 많이 밀집되어 있습니다
그리고 최근에 여기에 있는 빌딩들을
명품 기업이 직접 매입을 했습니다
그래서 진짜 1조가 넘는 금액으로
매입을 했는데 지금 샤넬 있는 건물도
매입한 것처럼 지금 5번가에 있는
건물들도 이런 명품 기업들이 좀
매입을 하고 있어요 지역이 임대료도
워낙 높고 그리고 들어갈 자리도 많이
없거든요 그래서 이런 명품 기업들이
좀 어떻게 보면 입지를 미리 확보하기
위해 가지고 임대보다 뭐 빌딩 매입도
직접 한 것으로 좀
보여집니다 저는 432 파크 애비뉴
앞에 와 있습니다 그래서이 지금 파크
에비뉴 같은 경우에도 엉만 장자의
길의 대표적인 초고층 빌딩이라고
보시면 될 거 같아요 그래서 높이가
무려
426m니다 파크 에비뉴 같은
경우에도 펜트하우스가
2016년도에 약 한 9,500만
달러 그니까 하나로 치면 한
1,300억 정도에 이제 매각된
사례가 있었고 그리고 21년도 매물이
나왔었는데 하나로 치면 한
2,300억 정도의 어 매물이 나왔던
그런 사례가 있습니다 외국인들이
굉장히 좀 투자를 많이 하고 있어요
그래서 뭐 진짜 중국인들도 많이
매입을 하기도 하고 진짜 별장으로
많이 쓴다라고 합니다 그래서 그만큼
전 세계인들이 뉴욕에 많이 투자를
하고 있고 그리고 이런 초고층 빌딩에
많이 투자를 하고 있는 거 같습니다
그래서 아직까지 우리나라에는 이런 좀
초고층 빌딩도 많이 없을 뿐더러
이렇게 진짜 1천억이 넘는 그런 주거
시설 그니까 이제 주택들이 많이 없는
거 같아요 그래서 뭐 최근에 뭐
압구정에 분양하고 있는 것도 막 진짜
펜트하우스가 600억 700억 그리고
이제 뭐 잠원동에 있는 것도 막
600억 700 뭐 700억 800억
막 이렇게 얘기하고 있긴 하지만 아직
우리나라에는 이렇게 1천억 넘는
주택들이 좀 많이 없는 거 같습니다
그래서 저 개인적인 생각은 우리나라에
이런 진짜 초고층 주택들을 좀 많이
지어서 진짜 1천억이 넘는 그런
주택들이 좀 많이 나왔으면 좋겠어요
진짜 그 우리나라 사람들만 투자하는게
아니라 지금 뉴욕에 있는 것처럼 좀
이런 외국인들이 어 우리나라에 많이
그런 좀 상징적인 부동산에 많이
투자를 했으면 좋겠습니다 어
우리나라의 이런 주거를 만드는 분들이
뭐 물론 이제 많이 오시겠지만 이런
뉴욕의 초고층 주거 시장을 좀 많이
경험을 해봤으면 좋겠습니다 그래서
아마 여기서 저도 좀 많이 보긴
했지만 굉장히 좀 따올 만한 것들이
굉장히 좀 많거든요 그래서 여기를 좀
많이 참고해서 우리나라에도 좀
접목시켜서 주거 시장을 좀 더 이렇게
업그레이드 했으면 좋겠습니다
[음악]
저는 화려한 타임스퀘어를 보여 드리기
위해서이 늦은 저녁의 타임스퀘어에
왔습니다 정말 많은 사람들이이 화려한
전광판 거리를 보기 위해서 모였습니다
여러분들도 만약에 뉴욕에 오신다면
타임스퀘어의 야경을 꼭 보셨으면
좋겠습니다 그리고 제가 오늘 미드타운
쪽에 부동산을 좀 설명을 드렸는데
앞으로 좀 더 유익한 정보들도 많이
준비를 했으니까 다음 편도 기대해
주시면 좋을 것 같습니다 끝으로 제가
타임스퀘어 야영을 준비하고 여기서
마무리 짓도록 하겠습니다 여러분들
만세
[음악]
know in
the my mind find the
Words I can't to I
Don't
[음악]
Try
we we
SH we
[음악]
sometimes
me you little B
[음악]
of come little
cl do you qu pretend
tru never hear me
now me for